so we're gonna set this net we're gonna
catch ourselves a bunch of salmon if we
have different kinds of salmon that come
here and we're gonna make dog food and
people food and food for gifts and
giving and trading and whatever else we
feel like doing for the hailstones it is
crucial to harvest migrating salmon to
survive the coming winter they will
spend several days net fishing a native
method that has been passed down for
generations check it out you can see the
fish splashing already fun so we're
hoping there's quite a few fish out
there feel free to advance in the boat
thank you your bring it up side bring it
up side Oh
fish on hey we're definitely gonna have
salmon dinner tonight
that was fun watching the fish get
caught to the net as you pull it have a
salmon for dinner salmon are valuable
resource really valuable in Alaska tasty
fish
they're full of fats full of oils
they've got a lot of good vitamins and
minerals and proteins and it's all just
good for you it's fish it's brain food
you know I got to fish but it's still
catching the boat more than it's
catching fish buton not a good boat
checking your net in everything is
caught on everything
hey boats a good boat to check a net in
if you're really trying to but this
one's not ideal this one right here has
lots of snags and rivets and screws and
or locks and back corners we have an
older boat that's a Boston Whaler and
I'm thinking I'm gonna go pick that up I
had an old boat that we were using for a
net checker and now it has a leak that's
irreparable and it just sinks as we fill
it up with more and more salmon it sinks
lower lower and filled with more water
but have a brand-new motor coming so
I'll have an extra motor I'm gonna go
pick the wife up our really good fishing
boat that we have over at our son's
house he'll have real smooth sides and
my wife will fish to her heart's delight
without snagging anything while checking
net I'll have two motors I'll have two
boats we've got six good fish seven good
fish yep no complaints about that
hmm